[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to another
user interface tutorial for the G engine
this one's going to be short and sweet I
was going to add this in the last
episode but it just getting too long so
today we're going to be adding the
ability to delay your animations within
your animation component um if this is
new to you what we've been working on is
this animation component node and script
that is allowing us to easily create
animations for any user interface
control nodes we've already set up a a
hover effect uh so you can hover on and
off and we've added a bunch of different
options and so today we're going to add
the ability for that that delay uh as
always if you'd like to uh grab the
source files for this tutorial previous
UI tutorials and future UI tutorials as
well as every other go tutorial that
I've created you can grab those as a
patron of my patreon all right so in our
animation component script we've got a
lot more going on from the last episode
let's just add a little bit more to get
that delay now where we want to add this
delay is in our um add tween function
this function is uh where we're doing
the the animations for our our control
nodes we're using twins there is a
built-in sort of delay interval in fact
I'll type it out I've not gotten it to
work um so I'm I'm doing a different
method but
but maybe if it works for you that's
awesome it's it's not super reliable
but it's this uh twen interval function
right down here and so what that does is
it it delays by certain amount this
could be um you know 0.1 seconds and
then you're waiting for that timeout and
then it continues because you're doing
this uh the await we're going to do a
different variation of that again
because it's not working for me let's
jump up to our export values first so
we've got all of these different
properties settings that we can adjust
for whenever we're we're hovering on and
off of our control nodes and what we
want to do is just add another parameter
here or another variable rather and this
is going to be called hover delay this
will be a float and this is going to
allow us to asset um a value in seconds
that the the anim will delay so if we
wanted to wait a second before the
animation goes we put in one now that we
have our exort variable we need to add a
new parameter to our ad tween function
we already have our our values
dictionary that we're passing through uh
we're setting whether or not we're
running everything at the same time with
parallel seconds is how long the
animation takes and also our transition
type and easing type so we want to add
in a new one in fact let's let's keep it
near seconds since it deals with time
and we're call this
delay and that will be a float and I
know we're getting a lot of parameters
in there but that's a okay now that we
have that let's jump up to our connect
signals area where we're calling that
function we've connected that function
we're binding our parameters here and we
need to add that parameter now that
we've we've created it in our function
and we added it after time it has to be
the same order otherwise it's going to
get confused you got to load it in the
same order just as if you were calling
the function right so we did it after
time so after time we'll add in our
hover delay
variable in both cases and now we fill
those out so it's going to be super
happy worth us and now we can get down
into our add twen function and actually
add the delay so again I had issues
getting this to work I I at some point
it did work and then it freaked out and
it just it would not do anything so
here's my method my workaround for that
and I will also note that you can set a
delay for each of these properties but
then you're setting them for the
property and if you weren't running them
at the same time it would be between
each individual
one that might work you could do that
method if you wanted to um but this
seems to to do okay for me so after we
set whether or not we're running
everything at the same time with our set
parallel we're going to
pause we're going to pause our tween
we're going to allow all of these
properties to create it's a weird issue
of uh pausing and then setting a timer
and then the properties load and they
don't have what they need to run so
we're just going to pause everything all
of these properties will get created
and then we'll run our
await get
tree create timer and that's where we're
going to use our our delay parameter
right there we'll wait for that
to oh I wish I could type
timeout and then after that's
done then we play it just with that we
we should be good and we can actually
test this so let's go into our animation
component we have our delay let's delay
that for a second so what this means
again I'll will hover on the button and
it won't do anything won't animate for a
second that's the
delay and we can change that
to you know 0 2 it'll be shorter on off
that's all it takes to add just a nice
delay to your animations if you need
them add a little bit more control pause
your tween fill out your properties
through your Loop wait for that timeout
and then restart your tween that seems
to take care of it and it also fixes
some other issues with the timing if
you're you're adding these delays it
gets a little weird again if this works
for you that's great I can't get it to
work it might be the um the version I'm
in or something or I don't know it it
should work but I think this this Loop
kind of it throws it for a loop so
anyway that's how you do it nice and
quick in the next episode we're going to
add in that ENT two animation and we'll
uh we'll start moving on from animations
and and get into some actual user
interface stuff because at least we can
make it look pretty now right all right
so uh yeah that's it as always thanks
for watching and keep creating all right
guys if this tutorial was helpful
consider it a like And subscribe to the
channel as we're going to be covering a
lot more thanks to all of my patrons who
keep the series going you too can get
access to the project source files by
joining my patreon you can download
everything there and you'll also get
early access to my videos and sneak
peeks at Future tutorials thanks for
watching and as always keep creating
[Music]